o tac longe como é que sua falta de
pessoal de quem fala é dar que sejam
muito bem vindos
é mais um esplendoroso vídeo existe este
objetivo expandir o zune eventual
estamos aqui para fazer um vídeo bem
diferente do que o país já costumeiro
aqui no canal no entanto um vídeo com a
participação do uso que você também tem
muito hoje nós vamos estar aí é semana o
banho de final - olha eu consigo
explicar aí o pessoal aqui da casa que
não conseguia dizer e aí a semana sabe o
que uma pessoa que nunca viu o mar diz
quando viu o mar pela primeira vez ia
ser mar
ok enviada quando é que o amor é esse o
nosso líder que não viu o irmão não
quiserem não deixei lá e faço o que
posso dizer é não ser só voltou a ficar
escondido aqui no canal dos tanques
quiserem ver mais cometem como fofinho e
toda a gente gosta em princípio podem
porque lá desde já com os pais com uma
semana como essa prima estamos aqui
tentar fabricar visualizações no canal
por canal fácil um pouquinho
então temos que seguir à ii divisão
posições em voltar mas o que é eu voltar
ao cockpit visualizações e que o cão é
meu e queijo que mostra lá quem manda
aqui no canal do jockey
agora só porque não tinha suzuki suzuki
é da raça moído os a moeda com design no
brasil meu irmãozinho muito peludo
aliada não é um cavalo um beijinho
beijinho beijinho
ai que fofo tomava então hoje vai ser
curioso que só espero que vocês gostem
vamos lá
ah
é a
só
ah
[Música]
o
paulo
qualquer só vou tentar enganar o uso que
ocupa em um biscoito que é um aqui no
mercosul
vamos ver se o local é uma curva
kuito bié e muito bem uma coisa que já
percebi é que se eu comer os alimentos
que estudar o zouk eu automaticamente
como ok só agora vou comer uma banana é
minha fã é minha
o que quer dizer que tenha em cima ou eu
falo com quem o cheiro do que consegue
ouvir me quiserem fazer isso em casa com
os nossos animais atenção tenho muito
cuidado porque afetam e menos tóxicos
praticamente que elas não podem comer
coisas que nós conseguimos que o
chocolate eo vai abarcar são coisas
tóxicas pregão e tudo que eu sei que são
coisas que fazem mau uso que ok então
tem muita atenção com comida que vocês
nossos animais que foi nada de 14 nada
de açúcar nada de sal gordura
principalmente sabem fritos e coisas
assim aqueles que comem se vocês verem
os vão comer e não vai passar nada mas
se vocês querem continuar sushi simples
o campo pode passar mal
o queijo queijo mais banana já o asa que
não é mais veneno até que o recinto toma
eu não sei se eu como a casca tomar
caxito com a macaca como a casca homem e
alimenta o planeta e as pessoas que
tenham estado que distribui já falam em
portimão com nossa família e amigos
deixem muito mais que nos tire uns
quiser mais riscos
que cometi e e só fiquem vai até a
frança um breve